i'm surprised you ain't seen like my
cardi b impression
that one like
so i met cardi b and she was like oh
that's that girl that does the
impression of me
[Laughter]
hello everyone hola mis amigos
sport sporting paul
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg
sunday lawn care helps you grow
beautiful lawn without guesswork or the
nasty chemicals get 20 off your full
season custom plan go to
getsunday.com slash
omg
high 20. what about how can you
how can how is that possible
how's what is it what is this
well the custom plant includes
fertilizer and everything you need to
easily care for your lawn and with
ingredients like seaweed iron and
molasses since you can make a pot of
green oh no you can feel good with the
kids and the pets being around wow
oh yeah.com
put in your address and their lawn
analysis tool does the rest
they then use soil and climate data
to create personal nutrient plan
delivered to your door when you need it
just attach a ready-to-use pouch to a
garden hose and spray it takes less than
15 minutes best of all this stuff
really works easy delivery and no more
picking up heavy fertilizer at the
hardware store
and sunday is offering 20 off for our
listeners
full season plans start at 120
full season plans start at just 129
and then you get 20 off uh check out
when you get sunday dot slash
oh my god hi
20. that's 20
off your custom play listen if you can
get [ __ ] latinos to start using
molasses in their lawn care
that's a [ __ ] company that you can
live with
molasses
i've never seen anything so beautiful my
life edit the [ __ ] out pull the canela
to the grass
20 off your custom plan get sunday.com
omg high 20. listen
uh
you know chicanos
we're not as much as dick size as we are
what our lawns look like okay so it's
very important that our lawns uh stay
right that's right because you'll be
judged my grandfather went to mexico and
his the front yard was his most prized
possession which i didn't water from the
time he left
until i found out he was an hour away
from coming back
so i went out there and i tried to spray
water to make it look like i had been
watering and i sprayed it on the on we
had these bushes on the side they were
already like pretty big and i sprayed
them on them to look like the whole yard
had been wet and the minute he got out
of the car he said did you just spray
those bushes with a water circuit look
like you've been watering
when i was in high when i was in high
school
the first
time i went to the comedy store
in westwood i was in it was cinco de
mayo weekend i was still in high school
i think it was actually may 5th and my
first comedian that went up was yakov
smirnoff
so he comes up there and he's like i'm
from russia he's doing a thing and the
first two minutes is a little bit like
you know looking around this guy for
real and then at the end
he's just killing him man just killing
him just destroying him oh he was he was
great yeah
but but in modern
warfare who is this and then you come
around but no no but on stage
[Laughter]
but that guy went
and then i saw him one time
at the comedy store on sunset in the
afternoon doing his act with nobody in
the room but doing his act completely
from beginning to end he'd bend down and
talk to somebody and go over there i was
in the back and i was like wow man
that's a [ __ ] trip like the
discipline i respect a rehearsal like to
do that like to discipline i can't first
of all i can't do it that's what we do
in acting but then to do that in
standing in scandal
i'd love to talk to you about that can i
go oh yeah absolutely
so he knew he was but he knew where he
was going doesn't get rattled like us
you're like a boxer who has a plan
you can [ __ ] your first couple punches
don't [ __ ] hit you're like
you change your [ __ ] script hey i saw
that
thing on channel five you did
other pretty that was my ad-libbing hey
[Laughter]
and i didn't know my wife sent it to me
uh and i caught it uh i was just firing
man you know yeah it was those are just
firing i was excited i said [ __ ] channel
five guild creo yeah he called me his
co-host oh yeah
damn that that that's big stuff to call
him mr lopez but your
co-host no no no no no no no no no no no
no no i'm not i i genuflect
and uh
grant here will make a comment and
identify
did you bring your clip did you bring
your clip of you meeting that dude from
the news no they haven't sent me the
link got it out yet right yeah i'll get
it hopefully i'll have it uh
tomorrow what's that some wood right
there yeah
um we post this on the instagram this
was from uh it's raul carrillo at raoul
arts on instagram dude yeah
he did he put up like a time lapse of
this thing it's
gorgeous it's this this phenom and he's
had a couple of other pieces is that
wood yeah it's wood he did is it carving
or painting i'm not fully uh i think
clearly i'm not i don't know
paints and he's even even got the beer
cans in there
at the bottom that's that's a phenomenal
piece of work
it's remind me after we're done you're
asking me to remind you after we're done
remind us after we're done i have uh
i think i do
have with his wife uh
look at that that's amazing scent
that's one of the things about
you know either what do you call a
social media or whatever the people that
used to just draw in their rooms and go
grandpa what are you making
now everybody can see you know now yeah
nobody's talent should go unnoticed yeah
everybody can change you know
nobody's telling should go on
um i want to make can i get some behind
the scenes or will you be busy the whole
time oh i mean you you can go so aaron
are we already rolling
we're we're rolling we can cut it up but
you're welcome to do whatever okay but
you guys are taking video sorry i can
okay are you fr are you from
well you want to introduce a guest i
don't want to get it did you bring slot
one thing at a time ta-da yes here
george i want you all right oh these are
the one thing at a time okay okay all
right joining us today on the podcast is
let me take your things away from you
because no those are your things
uh digital content creator comedian and
actress and fellow minnesotan which i
appreciate uh natalie friedman and also
a fellow podcaster host of the ladies
room podcast on sirius xm the ladies
room podcast the ladies room are we
allowed to listen yes
it's a lot it is literally a group of
girls like they're in the bathroom what
is the main thing about women that they
about relationships or any you know i
think there's more
i want to say
person male same-sex arrangements than
when you were growing up maybe
when i was
you know how advanced we are as a
culture but you know
i don't believe that there was as many
people who were living their best life
as they say in the seventies and
eighties
absolutely but then you have to live
in a bit of a
a bit of a say lie but a bit of a thing
where you
feel especially when you're in small
towns where you feel like you're
it's not safe maybe yeah or not
you know your family it's hard to think
that
your family would would turn on somebody
but they you know they do they do you
know yeah and i'm gonna drive in the
closet yeah and that's
do they say closet though they did say
clown who's it okay
you would probably i would probably pick
like pantry
yeah if you say closet
right it's like you're a murderer would
be in the closet but somebody's in the
walk-in pantry the pantry it does sound
like you're in there you're going out
you're just arranging i take the pantry
there's food in there checking the
expiration dates
it's all about living your best life all
about it it's 2022. i think it is i
think it's uh
i think it is we're living in the times
of
accepting everyone as we should and
there's people that that do not
yes
and and you know when someone is so
whether it's anything politically
understandable but
when somebody is just against people for
the way that they
look i'm not talking about the people in
my neighborhood there are or who they
love who are who they love i would be i
would be
eventually you know i evolved but i
would be happy if mine was with whoever
she was with my daughter exactly it's
like
then i judge the parents i'm like who
raised you to be like this
so you know and you saw american beauty
yeah
in american beauty was
the next door neighbor father was he gay
was he closeted i think it's been a
while since i've seen it but but the
mom's remember the mom was like really
afraid to talk
and and
kind of living just like
like she was being
suppressed yeah and very kind of i think
which is what a lot of way
mom some moms were but you know this is
the best intro i've ever had
everyone's like what's
you said where you have the podcast
where you speak freely about
men out about everything about
everything yeah yeah we talk about pop
culture we talk about our periods we
talk about dating texting being single
being in a relationship
um and our male producer is like i've
learned so much from you guys
it i don't know if you catch the right
or wrong episode it might be very gory
it might be you know girl it's it's girl
talk do people talk have you guys talked
about people that decide to live alone
because because they've not had good
luck in relationships
we i think we've touched on like
pandemic loneliness of like living alone
um but i don't know if we've yeah for
life
yeah i don't know if we talked about
like that decision but um that's pretty
heavy that's an interesting topic
especially these days yeah i was reading
the other day about this actress who
came out as asexual and i thought that
was really fascinating like i i you know
um again i'm not coming back
which one is asexual that they have no
sex at all she's yeah she wrote very
openly how she doesn't have a desire to
you know being a relationship she's not
defined by it she's not necessarily
attracted
to either gender you know i don't really
fully understand it
is that what's considered asexual yeah i
think so she's not a desire to have sex
or be in a relationship at this time in
her life and i think some people can be
like asexual and romantic still like
they'll you know they can form
connections but for whatever i saw a
show on tlc where somebody was in love
with the chair have you seen those shows
no not saying that
george you watch those
did you see my octopus teacher yeah
that's that's a living thing though at
least nothing but in you in the water
they were holding hands
and then when the dude didn't go by back
for a couple days she got mad yeah what
so what natalie's announcing is she's in
love with two octopi
and she needs to choose which octopi has
the bigger tentacles
we got 16 options between
he knew when they were upset through ink
at his ass like i'm sorry babe
i wanted to ask you so i was
i've watched her stand up
i was a kid and i've watched some clips
but i think but i think in my stand-up
you know i'm an only child so i i i
think that i'm
i'm not sure who i am in the stand-up
because i don't think i've really you
haven't gone on i haven't really
don't think i've found who i am i think
that i'm
it's ever evolving but i was going to
say you are so good at improv
and you are so good at
telling that like i feel like i feel
like i'm in your family how can you tell
that
i mean i did stand up not on your level
but like but can you but right maybe you
did rehearse those but can you see it
can you see can you tell when someone's
improving
i thought you were
yes and a lot of those i was and a lot
of those are live yeah so i was like i
think this is improv and if it because
you're so organic and they would say to
me
how do you improv
doing a live show
and i would would say you know like and
you're very physical in a good way that
thank you
like the spine has discs
in between the disc is the cartilage
or whatever that's called
and in between those discs is where i
improv
in between it's like a song it's like a
music now a little bit
like i wrote a joke where they yell at
kids that aren't even born yet yeah
where the woman is
don't think that you're just gonna have
that baby and leaving with me and go do
whatever the [ __ ] you're gonna do who
are you talking to i'm talking to both
of you
i love how you said um you know i'd say
grandma and she'd say no like the
answers are good like i think so many i
grew up with russian parents and there's
so many similarities like papa no yet no
i didn't ask you again yet that was an
improv you don't even know what it is
but i know what it's not i know it is
not yeah
but my grandmother would
it's so funny isn't it like
can you see your grandparents and your
mom and dad
when you do stand up can you can you
visualize that the the
the places you're pulling your stand up
from yeah i go to the dinner table or
yeah and i i see their faces and yeah
but i think i think that you know i have
some friends that are mexican latino
latina and and the similarities between
how we grew up i think it's economical
with foreign parents i mean it's
economic too like you know this is this
is the difference between like
when you're starting in the 90s you know
people would say
well i don't know i didn't like it
because i don't speak spanish and i
don't i don't really kind of know that
life and then you get the show and you
start to do it a couple years and
they're like i think he's great because
it's like you know my parents are from
the ukraine that's the first one i heard
yeah that's the way our parents are foil
on the windows it's it's uh 98 degrees
outside and 111 inside
you know that we need to go outside
we used to have a swamp cooler in the
window that
was just it just rotated hot air
did you did you ever have a fear where
like if it's really hot out and the
parents turned the ac on as a treat then
you open the windows i thought a tornado
would start
somebody put it in my mind that that's
how tornados start really so when i was
a kid i'm like opening the window with
the ac
no i have three siblings ah and they are
uh
older brother two younger sisters oh wow
you're right in that yeah yeah so i'm
second and from minnesota from minnesota
you betcha i represent you
where in minnesota are you from uh so
i'm from andover which is like a half
hour north of the twins
i'm from bendover
i
what about you i'm from eden prairie
okay ep in the house yeah very cool so
so both of you
so we're from here we're you're from
where again uh i'm from pico you're from
hillcrest or something you're from
rivera
pico rivera was a character when i was
in high school i wanted to create a
character named pico rivera
like i said there was a guy and i
couldn't i wasn't doing characters
or do i but his name was pico rivera uh
so useful river i'm from about six miles
north of here
the five freeway and san fernando
mission in a cul-de-sac
which i didn't know i lived which i
didn't know meant dead end i grew up on
a cult sack you did yeah my house was on
the edge of one
we had i also grew up
wait a minute that's [ __ ] are you
serious 100 yeah did you think it was a
dead end or was it cul-de-sac it was a
dead end i thought it was a fun
cul-de-sac it was like dodgeball he'd
like round it out so it's a cul-de-sac
we were doing a thing for the golf
channel and we were going back to my
house i think my grandmother was still
alive and the guy that
was behind me stopped
and i and i got out of the car and i
said what was coming i want you to see
something
and i said what and he goes do you know
that you live on a dead end
and i said
i live in a cul-de-sac
and there was a sign when you go down my
street that's a dead end yeah it didn't
take long and i didn't know i don't know
what the [ __ ] jesus is the realtor
lovely cul-de-sac right up against the
five freeway
uh i would be on the phone and they
would say what the [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
ocean because all the cars going by yeah
oh wow
and uh yeah i didn't know i didn't know
if it was a
you know i was already an adult before i
fully understood that i grew up on a
date we actually painted a diamond
so we could play ball
on our deck oh nice did you play
dodgeball in the cul-de-sac no we played
baseball we played baseball yeah we'd
use a tennis ball so it's not to break
well there's not a [ __ ] baseball it's
a tennis ball
[Laughter]
simulated baseball using a tennis ball
but home plate was right in the middle
of the dead end and then first base
second base would have been right in the
opening and third base was over here
we can't believe that so much mayhem
could happen on a little street this guy
had a bb gun and his dad comes out and
says hey
point that
it's one of those pump ones last one the
last one
and he goes point that up or down so he
points it down there's a kid across the
street getting into the station wagon
he points it down it shoots it ricochets
off the street hits the kid in the ear
so we see this kid jumping up and down
and we're like what the [ __ ] is that and
he started gage pierce and he and he had
the bb in his ear
no damn awesome that kid was a pioneer
was awesome
hit the ball hard there was an old lady
she had to be about 65 old 65 years old
up the street
and the ball hit her
and what do we do everybody drops their
gloves and everything just runs
your license there
you don't have a license but but so how
do you how do how does how do you guys
end up deciding first of all
the notion of coming to california
and then how do you guys manifest it how
do you make it happen
please our guest should go first
vision board meditation
visual noise in school at school you
were in theater and you can sing i'm
sure i did dance team i'm i'm a decent
singer i wouldn't say amazing but i
always did i was on dance team since i
was a kid and i always did like comedy
rap yeah and i had some bars and so i
was always like doing that and like
doing impressions of impressions of like
teachers and like doing prank calls at
sleepovers so i knew i wanted to be a
comedian and then i'm like 12 years old
googling how do i get on snl
and it says you know you can do
groundlings or ucb so i actually went to
new york first i did ucb i started doing
stand-up there
and then
uh ended up like kind of going back and
forth doing the by coastal thing new
york la new york la and then finally the
pull was strong enough for l.a so i say
there's a i was in new york for nine
years so i kind of feel like i'm a new
yorker a little bit too yeah and and
when you went to new york did you go
alone did you yeah was it a big deal
like you told you but you drove over
there uh no no i took a flight
shipped boxes
um yeah i was by myself in new york city
it was a big move it was a big move what
do you remember from those times from
that time i literally remember the
moving day and like the flight and the
plane ride like so vividly like never
forget and my cousin lives in new jersey
and as a gift she got me like car
service from the airport to my place
and it was so nice of her and i remember
having two roommates at that first
apartment i vividly remember like a
studio bedroom yeah it was yeah and i
just i remember walking outside being
like i'm in manhattan this is it
do you talk to the roommate still no
no
no there wasn't a bad ending it's
because because you you because you're
one of those people that sees all of the
things that they probably wouldn't see
what what traits did each of those
roommates have
uh they they partied a lot more than i
did yeah yeah
but they weren't in comedy or anything
they were just one of them was an
actress yeah
yeah
and then one of them um her dad was a
doctor
and i had like a
like a weird cyst on my arm it came out
so he came over once for probably not a
weird says any system
my health insurance wasn't set up yet i
was like
man i asked her ahead of time but i'm
like could you look at this next time
he's around it was great it was like i
got that what did he say oh you have a
weapon like it's nothing it'll go down
warm compress warm compress and it went
down
what is assist by the way that's it
i wish i had a doctor in my family but i
would annoy them with every little
question
are you
i mean here are you know radical about
your health
a little bit like i'm a health nut yeah
i think it comes with like yeah you get
a car i go down a rabbit hole in google
things i shouldn't go i've gotten better
though i won't like google as many
things what are some of the traits that
people who are jewish have that not
necessarily but one of them is the
cornerstone trait is that we're worried
warts yeah like every little we always
think of the worst case scenario in
business and everything but i think in
business it's a smart thing you have to
look at the best case scenario yeah and
the worst case and then what i call the
medium case the and then it's as long as
you know that spectrum yeah what's ours
that we're you know every day we're
unhappy i don't have one
i don't have one i don't think it's
impression i think you might do you
think you did you do you think you have
that trait to worry
about little things you know what my
grandmother was
would be like i worry about you
and i'll be like i think you should
worry about yourself
uh i can't help it
so she worried so much that
she didn't live her life yeah you know
she didn't have a good life because she
was worried about
the lamp i'm worried that the lamp
is going to fall and hit me right it's
like a sense of letting go right there's
a sense of surrender let go and let god
or whatever your belief system is but i
think i've gotten better at that as i
get older it's like you just saw like
you but you weren't but you weren't
afraid though right i mean you know some
people i was when i was a kid i was
afraid of everything like i could not
have moved if if somebody would have
said to me if i lived in denver and they
said if you move you you want to move to
l.a to be a comedian on your own i would
have said i can't i i can't
i wouldn't nothing's ever frightened me
except for to this day
mice mouse
a little mouse
a little mouse
is a big [ __ ] rat to me
and you know the your cartoons elephant
jump on the table that's me wow
i'm scared okay so where did that come
where does that come from vietnam
i had never seen
nothing ever bothered me and then they
show you all these movies and you see
preparing you for rats over there then i
saw the rats one night around one like
this
i'm scared to death of them so if you
lived in new york city and you see the
big racks running by like you would i
just saw a clip where the rats and your
bunches are like flocks they're thick
and they were big they got ass they got
juicy rats yeah did you see the rat that
was taking you was a regular bath oh
wait no i haven't seen him and he was
using the soap he was going like this no
way
see let's see if i can find it i think
it was a rat he had a cyst on his arm i
had a sister underneath hey look at this
that's this weird thing he's cleaning up
because the doctors are getting possibly
came over and looked at it no there's
like i guess there's like i haven't done
it but from what i've seen there's like
therapy for fear so it's like exposure
therapy so what if they like that is
this it look at this mother oh hell
he's suddenly done that's adorable he's
running himself we'll link this right in
the shower what if you how is that real
i mean those human mannerisms no i can't
through a lens i would not be close
enough
he's he's taking a bath like a person
but he did the milly right he did his
ass
he did it but he cleaned his ass yeah
that's something i don't even know i
don't even do it
that was adorable but frightening at the
same time i mean that i mean that was
crazy wow i've never seen that before
that they do that wow so your your
grandmother was a worrywort you're a
father i'm a father do you think you're
worrying at that level or do you have
that let go you have that let go level
i've let it go your daughter yeah yeah
i've let it go and it's like trust in
her trust in everything's gonna be okay
yeah i mean she went to school in london
and then she went to school in chicago
and she's wow travel at a young age like
we travel at a young age which i think
helps kids did your family travel yeah
where did you guys go to pike's peak or
whatever
we went to wisconsin
i took some trips i went to russia to
visit my grandpa because he never
officially left there so went to visit
him so yeah we traveled how was that to
go back there
it was my first time going there and he
still lived there he got remarried um
because my grandmother left alone with
my mom when i immigrated here so it's
very unique for a woman to immigrate by
herself at that time period and going
back to you know seeing where my mom
grew up seeing the schools she went to
it was pretty incredible yeah what did
you see what kind of was it i literally
saw her school
um and then my grandpa's place um he
didn't even have wi-fi so i went to the
coffee shops to get on wi-fi they don't
have wi-fi he just he he just chose not
to have it i mean i i don't know if i'm
completely safe i think it's
i think that's might be better though i
think they had like tv and stuff but it
was yeah he was still living in an
old-fashioned way you know it's funny
like you said they have tv and like
maybe there's two channels of just snow
but you prefer one versus the other one
but i think eventually they got it
because then we started facetiming him
from yeah so i think yeah it's like when
we got there it wasn't fully set up but
but uh more importantly it was so cool
to see
my roots and
you know see where my mom grew up
support for the oh my god high podcast
is provided in part by sunday lawn care
it's hard to imagine but spring is
almost here we're so close to feeling
that soft grass under our feet but first
we need to get our lawn back thankfully
sunday gets your lawn growing and helps
to keep it healthy all season long
sunday can help you grow a beautiful
lawn without the guesswork or the nasty
chemicals their custom plans include
fertilizer and everything you need to
easily care for your lawn and with
ingredients like seaweed iron and
molasses
you can feel good with kids and pets
being around all you have to do is visit
sunday.com put in your address and their
lawn analysis tool does the rest they
then use soil and climate data to create
a personal nutrient plan delivered to
your door just when you need it just
attach the ready-to-use pouch to your
garden hose and spray it takes less than
15 15 minutes and best of all this stuff
really works
sunday's offering all of our listeners
20 percent off full season plans start
at just a hundred twenty nine dollars
and you can get twenty percent off at
checkout when you visit get sunday dot
com slash omghi 20 that's 20 off your
custom plan
at getsunday.com
omghi20.
i think uh i you know i've never been
old before
but i think that um a lot of time is is
wasted i think maybe be on
you know we're in the business of social
media but a lot of kids that spend most
of their time either on their phones or
you know um on their computers
or whatever that is that that that's
time away from
almost a reality nature relationship yes
grandparents and parents and things
where you know i saw a meme where
everybody had their phone out and there
was an older lady that was just kind of
on the rail watching
there's like a dinner table
yeah and there is something to
to that to seeing
i think for me the most telling thing
about stuff like that is how people who
work at like facebook instagram etc tell
their kids like don't go on there don't
use it like or they have like extreme
time limits exactly like these are the
people making the product they know how
the sausage is made and they're telling
their family not to engage but they're
like you know
a friend of mine told me that
his wife i went down when his his
daughter and their friends were there
and they were like crackheads they were
just
they were like you got to put it what's
the matter
it's not up it's not up oh my gosh i
mean they lost their they lost their
minds like i'm thinking because they
lost their minds and they were like 13
and they lost their loss their minds is
it is it almost like a like in that
movie she is it a virtual
her friend
her
come on pronouns uh uh i feel well i
mean we already know that dopamine and
serotonin and nor you know those those
feel-good addictive receptors are
activated when you're on when you're
getting these likes and and if somebody
has an addictive personality then it's
multiplied and ginseng has grown up i
actually for for being on social media i
i try to try to not scroll i try to shut
off my phone and not be on my phone an
hour before bed so i can like
but it's yeah i've
i have younger nieces and they're
they're on their phones yeah and you
can't and you can't get and you can't
get to them so when you were in new york
did you did you go to did you work
yeah yeah i i so i was part-time nanny
at first
and then i so that was like survival job
and then i did some fit modeling which
helped pay the bills and just kept then
voice over
did voiceover work and just kept
building and building and
started getting on stage doing stand-up
and this was like
instagram was out but i i wasn't really
using it yet and then i started doing
impressions in my stand-up and getting
the biggest laughs with it so i'm like
oh why don't i put it on
on instagram and then it started to get
some intention and it all fit with me
wanting to be on snl do you know that
she does impressions
no i didn't i was watching her this
morning but i didn't see any impressions
fantastic impressions i i didn't see
anyone you know you got to watch out
with the word fantastic because why
maybe
maybe 20 some years ago
i ran into a dude i worked on him with a
movie and he said fantastic all the time
and then i started saying it and once
you start saying it is it corny [ __ ]
stuff i say it in emails i say i hope
you're having a fantastic week should i
kind of stop what you think the dessert
fantastic exactly i think it's better
than wonderful though wonderful
great song
keeping fantastic
he's great i think we're three fantastic
today
will you keep track of fantastics
you i'm surprised you ain't seen like my
cardi b impression
that one like
so i met cardi b and she was like oh
that's that girl that does the
impression of me
[Laughter]
and like so [ __ ] so cardi b like
reposted the impression i did
in like 2018 so like a lot of my
followers are latina that cardi b
followers and like some of them are like
are you spanish i'm like damn i'm
flattered
so like some people still don't i still
get comments like what are you
like i'm like i'm nardi b like what you
mean so that was a that was a popular
one she she kind of she amazing she put
me on the map and like reposted me and i
i always give her her thank you for that
because i i got like 200 000 followers
and when you're finding it are you yeah
are you trying to there's a rhythm of it
right everybody has it
finding the impression
yeah like recording like how i like
see how my mouth is you like it's a big
she don't got a big mouth but i have to
do that and i got to use my tongue and i
gotta like
really like smack my lips yeah that's
what i'm noticing when i put on fake
nails though that's how you
[Laughter]
she's like a little more still
and like puckers her lips and she's more
she's so sexy i love kim like i'm a fan
you know
and then like when melania trump was in
office i just look scared and squint
i look like i'm lost on the gps you just
look like look like your gps has you
lost and you're looking that [ __ ] is for
some eyes
um don't say it's fantastic i know i
have to stop what is it about that like
that where the [ __ ] are her eyes
so donald maybe doesn't really see what
i'm thinking
[Laughter]
defense mechanism
and uh britney spears is a popular one
too but i i'm so happy that things are
better for her now you know what i mean
um but
i love brittany does it was your
daughter a britney fan yeah of course so
did your um did your daughter ever have
like a wish list of people she wants to
meet and dad can i meet this person can
you help me the uh you know hillary duff
lived on our lived around the
neighborhood where we live hilary dawg
so mayan's in the backseat and she goes
hilary duff and i'm like that's not
[ __ ] hilary duff
and it was and then because of the
neighborhood and the jonas brothers
lived next door i mean they went from
frank zappa's house uh-huh to hillary
duff's house to the jonas brothers to
damon williams to jenny garcia i love
damon to
yeah to all of them and that
in that in my little
half cul-de-sac chase
did your daughter end up hanging with
hillary yeah came over you don't do
hillary though
not clinton yeah
the uh so this is this is the way
hillary duff was i did the hollywood
squares years ago and hillary duff was
on there and i asked her to do my show
because i thought she was older i
thought you're gonna say you asked her
for a ride home
i think she was driving back then she
was so this that's how i removed i
didn't know how old she was i said come
on the show we'll create a ca they go
george you know that she's 15.
you know i didn't know that she was 15.
yeah she she has she had a beautiful
mature look i think so we made her
a girl that sold cosmetics that was
older but looked 15
in order to
cover the thing and looking at the stuff
this morning i saw
uh
[ __ ] there you go kevin hart yeah there
was stuff with kevin hart yes there you
go kevin hart yeah and
didn't wasn't there also some stuff in
there with damon
not with damon a different black guy
does kevin hart scream all the time is
that his thing no
so he produces the ladies room
ironically yeah and and then we did some
sketches together uh in november so
he is such an amazing
entertainer comedian actor yeah
is it hard to do an impression of
someone to them because one of the
videos i saw in your tik tok was you oh
and kevin you know and you're making fun
of him i mean obviously
yeah
i mean yeah like with if i do an
impression of a man i'm not i know my
vocal register isn't gonna completely
get there so it's more like hey this is
my roast of you this is my essence of
you this is how i think you are but i
can't do a kevin hart voice but it was
fun to like you know he's he's very like
yeah like dope it's dope everything's
dope everything yeah i'm in the gym it's
5am yeah and the laughs work hard yeah
yeah yeah it's kind of you know so
he's he's amazing though thankful for
him
so there are some
good people to do impressions of uh
kim k was dead on melania i mean they're
really good yeah and kim kardashian i
met too and i did the impression fern
she was like i hope you get on snl and i
was like i hope kanye's okay
no i actually i'm i'm a fan of kanye i'm
a fan of the kardashians i think you
know people love to
be mean to them and say they don't have
talent
yeah i think they're business women and
they all have their individual
strengths you guys
did you know i was a kardashian can you
look up when i was in kardashian uh
i'm sure as hell about when i had my
talk you've never have you seen me as a
kardashian no
i
i don't know how the [ __ ] they got me to
do this i went to the teen choice awards
as a kardashian
in four years
and four makers which one were you or
were you just i was the oldest one i was
uh cougar kardashian oh wow
this i gotta see and uh please
does chris manage
i wasn't a kardashian long enough
we all ready to hurt i'll find a better
one but that is
that is
next to the car
legendary how did i miss that then on
the on the on this
on the talk show we had people do like a
documentary
i go higher i'm the oldest and the
hottest
uh but i mean come on man that is that's
down the [ __ ] hill at universal land
heels
wow oh man and spanx
and
compression underwear
wow um yeah but they they were actually
very cool and then um
we uh
did a thing with harvey levin and tmz
where we talked about all the lovers
that i had that were guys and then i got
out of the car and they did an upshot of
of my skirt and i had a penis wow
and they didn't blurt out they didn't
blur
that's how you got your own tv show and
then i was already in there
those are a lot of things i mean those
are funny yeah like i mean to be able to
do impressions and to you know step out
of stand up because stand up is a thing
but to be able to sing impressions and
doing brexit people are
awesome i saw the way that people
gravitated to those when you when you
did them yeah or even just act outs or
like you know just i have this like
super white girl character who just you
know just just acting out something so
somebody can really feel like yeah i'm
stepping out or you know so so uh with
the girl from tennessee i saw you what
what
what are the mannerisms of
of
like people from different regions have
different uh right it's because my i
grew up in the valley in the 70s with
valley girl the movie and all the whole
thing and that was the oh my god hi is
from like oh my god hi oh my god
and and that so was that the inspiration
yeah totally oh my god oh my god so
exactly that's where the turn valley
girl captain yeah
valley wow and
you you were probably in vietnam but it
got it got to be there was the valley
girls song yeah there was fast under
ridgemont high there was a bunch of um
movies of that stuff and that was all
bad news bears was shot in seminar
yeah i think like it's about research so
like with i have this character named
dottie so i had to research in tennessee
there's there's eastern tennessee
there's appalachian from the appalachian
accent it's a little faster it's like
it's like that hillbilly um that he'll
be stereotyping
they can't talk faster
but then if you're going closer to like
you know nashville it's not going to be
like that
it's going to be a little more draw
right so you got to research the the
area
what what part you can't just do a
general southern where in texas
louisiana are you are you dumping
where are you from
where in minnesota are you from you know
because if you're the the you bet you're
on yeah and the don't you know that's
more like duluth like but i have friends
like growing up like i call them like
the minnesota soccer moms they had like
the minnesota accent and then here's my
mom like natasha
i remember like
as a kid i was you know i didn't really
have many foreign friends i had some
like you know my high school was pretty
different
no but i mean uh no no i know i didn't
have a lot of friends that had parents
as immigrants yeah so they'd be like
what's your mom saying and like they
were like they were rude and they were
like why are your parents yelling i'm
like they're just talking
but i would be like mom don't call me
natasha call me natalie yeah
she'd be like natasha
and then i remember one time we went
through the taco bell drive-through and
my mom had a really strong accent and
she's like too sprite
taco and my friend was like what is she
saying
and i just like
i i mean i had those moments growing up
where i
you know and then i remember one time
she came to visit me
for lunch this is like and um these boys
in my class like made fun and they were
like who's the spanish girl and i was
like that's my mom but it's just like
that you know they don't know better but
it's like that typical
when i was doing the punchline in
sacramento we would always drink at the
club and then we would go to
the jack-in-the-box which was like a
mile down arden way and then we the guy
would say welcome to attack and i'm not
going to head through it
[Applause]
and i did the whole thing and on one of
my first very successful yeah
and then i did it on my show the first
the tv show where i had all my my mom's
friends in the car
and the guy like what are they yeah i'm
not gonna help you i'm like yeah you
want do you wanna
what kind of soda do you have a cocoa
we have a spray pick the guy said bexy a
spry
spray and then you're like what kind of
that's what kind of fountain drinks do
you have and the guy's like fountain
why not
stupid
but yeah did you have those moments as a
kid where you were made fun made fun of
or bullied or i was always embarrassed
of him or were you embarrassed of your
accents maybe maybe it's i think it was
a little more diverse my grandfather
worked in construction my grandparents
raised me my grandfather was not my
biological grandfather but he worked in
construction
and i don't know what the [ __ ] he was
doing at school he came in one day and
everybody looked at him at the same time
they all got scared
like he was in you know i guess they
said go to this club i don't know what i
forgot why would he be there and then
all of our you know heads were facing
this way and the teacher said can i help
you sir and everybody looked through the
date because you know [ __ ] he was
like he was out in the sun yeah and then
these workbooks you felt embarrassed
like yeah
it was crazy how you remember that
moment you go back to that moment you
remember it because nothing was
embarrassing i lived in an all mexican
neighborhood all mexicans everybody yeah
spoke the same way talk the same way
look the same way it's funny that in the
valley in my school that is all you know
i go back there and give toys now like
every year for like almost
that there was only one kid with a huge
head like a water head this would be
like a water head like the 99th
percentile
like you know up here and then and and
he [ __ ] took the bus from resida
to san fernando every morning because
our school was the only one where he
would take english as a second language
wow oh wow so his little [ __ ] great
gazoo head dude
was on this
and then the little original jacket
the rtd would pull up and then it would
be kind of kicking the ball the more and
everybody would go at the same time
get out of the out of the bus and we'd
always say like
i mean poor kid and he had i mean he
literally had
to take a [ __ ] bus 40 miles every day
to get to [ __ ] be insulted by us wow
i mean
awful
wow i mean really awful i mean but i
think you know i don't think that you
can sharpen the knives of comedy
if not at someone else's expense right
and if you don't have those those
moments
today he's the doctor in charge of covet
yeah yeah so so so
today are you have you
have you done have you done have you
been in movies and stuff like that like
i would say i would say that you should
have your own show i so that's what i'm
working on is developing my own job okay
yeah is kevin hart
helping you with that no not at the
moment okay yeah so that's all me but i
would love to have my own sketch variety
show absolutely yeah get you on there
working on that i've done some like
indie films
and uh done some voice over but you know
i think that that is a good thing as
well yeah
absolutely you know um
when
when my show was over like i remember
sitting there going you know what what
am i going to do
type thing and then i wanted to do more
dramatic stuff
so i started to look at
uh movies that were more dramatic but
even if it was like just a couple of
scenes like those guys were like uh you
know we can't find anything that's like
a big i said oh no i don't it has to
have to be a big part be like a smaller
like a smaller part i did like um
henry poole is here with luke wilson
then i did like um
adult balls of fury of course but those
are the 911 guys and then i did
um
like you know no man's land or river
runs red or all that stuff that was more
dramatic and i did a independent uh
movie for a girl that was looking out
here looking for to make her story like
just a little 15 minute thing
and uh if i was married i know my wife
would have said you're not doing that
before that was really a favor and from
that came something else that is like
really big but just as a favor like
somebody saw me in that little wow in
that little thing like instead of
sending a on the computer a link to your
bio i decided to help this person and
that thing got me something that's
that's
maybe the it's pretty big wow but just
doing that where most people would be
like no i don't want to do that but work
is work even sam jackson you know i did
a thing there's a movie called hail
hail caesar
and
uh michael anthony hall was i think
robert downey was in there and there was
the scene of
the mailman that i got
but then i was working in chicago so the
the
movie paid like a thousand and chicago
paid like four and i said well i'm not
gonna do movies i totally do hey man i
can't do it yeah i'm gonna go do chicago
and sam jackson did it this is the late
90s wow really and when i saw simon
started tom i said hey man i saw you in
that movie goes oh yeah it's just a
little day actor zach that's what he
said to me
and that's i don't think there's any
small parts no i don't think so yeah
it's like if the story is good and the
characters are obviously the writing has
to be good don't say yes to everything
but
yeah absolutely would you put your show
in something that's organic to you or
does does it not matter
yeah absolutely i'd love to infuse like
some of my family experience in there
and then do characters and impressions
and and you know i don't want to give
away too much about what it is but yeah
definitely definitely all the things and
have a lot of comedian and guests on i
think it's all about putting your
friends on putting your colleagues on
and is that what is that is that a
facebook show is that
can you do it uh
how do they do it i mean facebook is a
platform right now for a show but yeah i
was thinking a streamer or
you know yeah
are there any are there any i do some
impression of myself
you do some impressions of yourself i'll
do some impressions
he'll say he doesn't do good impressions
and then he'll whip out some fantastic
impression
let's see no i'll do it before okay okay
can't do it if he's looking at me
look at me don't look at me when i do it
so so um
have you been back to new york have you
worked back in new york yeah i've been
there a few times but i think i think um
yeah i like la i wouldn't say i like l.a
more they're both they're both totally
different but i've been back there have
some family in jersey so i love new york
it has it has my heart i think i always
had that new yorker attitude even as a
minnesotan
so it felt organic just i'm a really
hard worker and persistent and i love la
i love l.a
what's not to tell you there's only you
know people people will say you know
aren't people fake out there and it's
like no i have amazing friends it's all
about who you attract and what you're
around and
you know
i don't i don't experience that because
i'm i'm surrounded by good you know i'm
going to say that there's a bunch of
[ __ ] [ __ ] i mean yeah they're
everywhere though not just l.a they're
everywhere you can't just say that well
well i only i only live in l.a so i
always worry about the ones that are
everywhere
but the ones like
when i lived when i lived was growing up
over here
nobody was an [ __ ] like when i was
growing up nobody was maybe they might
say hey don't go on my yard don't ride
your bike in my yard
but in the neighborhood that i live in
that i wanted to live in maybe from the
time i was in fifth grade these are the
worst [ __ ] people that you can
imagine really i mean just
you know i've been there since
2014 they look at me like they don't
they can't believe i live there that's
first of all that's number one and you
can't hide that face yeah that you know
they come down if they know you're there
they're just walking but i i live kind
of there's a little and they walk
downhill and they're like this
they don't even pretend they just they
don't pretend i had to have a weed party
at my house or i did before the pandemic
every year
amazing
and i had a logo of
me jumping in the pool and the is a is a
is a marijuana leaf
and then on the neighbor next door app
they said
i saw this
who lives in the house that had the
marijuana leaf and all this music coming
out of there and you know what is that
saying to our kids in the neighborhood i
live up a [ __ ] hill ain't no kids
right saying to the kids enjoy yourself
yeah exactly and you know they're just
everything is about bitching about
everything
yeah that'll happen my daughter today
are you sure she's your daughter lives
in the same house that i grew up in
all she does oh yes when my uh when my
parents passed away my dad passed away
first when my mom passed away
uh
before we get to the actual subject we
have to tell you who's not around
anymore there's a bunch of brackets yeah
it was up to me to sell the house and
divide it between my six siblings
and so
when i got everything together put the
house up for sale my daughter says i
want to buy it
too many of my friends uh have children
they're married and they're still living
in an apartment
i don't have a husband i don't have kids
but i want to buy the house so when i do
get married
i have something to move did she save
money she saved the money she bought the
house rented it out until
she was ready now she's there
two kids and an old man and they live in
the same house that i grew up in
on the same cul-de-sac the dime the
baseball diamond's no longer painted on
the street but
same cul-de-sac that's pretty good to
keep it in the in the keep it in the
family house she wanted it so it's as
long as they're happy i really don't
care but
same neighborhood same everything that's
nice to keep it in there how did you
decide to
do you guys look alike a little bit is
that from the area
uh
one beer you guys look alike
how did you decide to but you weren't an
actor were you no no not at all so i
actually came up thinking i'd be like a
physics science sort of guy i was in i
went to college at johns hopkins i
thought i was going to do all that sort
of [ __ ] i had a total quarter life
crisis it was like not at all what i
really wanted quarter life with myself
yeah that was nice to be back there 19
at the time um and then i just i'd
always loved comedy i had always liked
loved writing and stuff like that so
what did you love in comedy uh david
letterman david letterman was like my
first love and then i got into um
varying like louis ck
john mulaney for a long time all that
sort of stuff
made it my mission to become a comedy
writer that could only pretty much
happen in one place los angeles so i
moved out here i was also listening to
podcasts at the time in the back it was
like 2015 when i'm like
it's too late i should have had a
podcast at this point i don't flash
forward to 2022 and and here i am and
i'm you know i get to do this i get to
work at atc where we make all sorts of
comedy content like i'm i'm blessed i'm
living my dream i'm going to tell you a
david letterman i was in front of the
comedy store probably like 1981
and howie mandel and david letterman and
um like argus hamilton were all there
but i see david letterman and i'm like
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] david letterman
so
i was too scared to go up and um
ask him for an autograph so a homeless
guy comes by hey man i gave him a pen
and a card i said can you go ask that
guy
for his autograph and he goes up there
and david turns around he sees this dude
and he's like yeah he writes it and he
said
beat it you deadbeat
could that's when you you he's so weird
now david brenner said one of the
funniest things i've ever heard he's
about sitting on the newspaper traveling
yes
sitting on the newspaper what's that
it was would you care
here's here's david brenner go ahead he
was on subway he says the subways were
really dirty at that time he says so i
got the newspaper and i put it down then
so i sat down on the newspaper and some
patrick came up and said hey excuse me
buddy
you you reading that newspaper he says
yes you know my yes i am you stood up
change your page and sat back down
that's incredible that was uh those are
our era did you guys put newspapers on
the toilets growing up
no
i cleaned the windows no not newspapers
i don't put anything is it i don't know
there's no baskets in the thing nobody
else no yeah guys i tell you what we
only had an hour today and if you
believe it we already hit it
this is it what do you mean for the po
this we've been in here for an hour
really yeah
oh so we have to end on did you guys put
newspapers
i mean we you should tell the people you
have somebody else coming i got to wrap
this up yeah the studio is
booked
oh amazing was it entertaining of course
but also i mean i don't speak for you
i'd love to have you back and have like
a oh you've got more time yeah we talked
about mice and accents and this was like
the funniest i thought
this was
this is the fastest hour i've i thought
we were here for 15 minutes and i got a
text from aaron being like hey
grandchildren i'm honored to be here i'm
a fan i'm a fan of yours so um but i'm
natalie friedman uh friedman is spelt
like fried man don't don't [ __ ] it up
don't mess it up sorry excuse my french
you can find me on instagram facebook
youtube everything what are some of your
favorite foods oh that's tough i i love
everything i'm very adventurous like i
love organ meat and like liver and like
steak and french food and escargot and
you don't love all that
everybody used to eat liver backing up
what the [ __ ] i didn't have iron and
stuff
i went to the union square farmers
market there was a specific stand i
would go and get lamb kidneys and cook
them and they're delicious i'm telling
you oregon meat
is underrated that's what how our
ancestors ate
i'll keep my organs crazy i'm always
talking about this when you boil them
like there's some weird foam that goes
to the top no
wait what no that doesn't happen
some weird foam
those are the neurons in the
brain thank you
you